قال مراسل الجزيره ان الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه اعترضت اهدافا جويه فوق مدينه
بيلجرود الروسيه قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه
للمره الثانيه هذا اليوم مع سماع ذوي
انفجارات وقال حاكم المقاطعه ان الدفاعات
الجويه تتعاملت مع ثلاثه اهداف فوق مدينه
بيلجرود ومحيطها مشيرا الى ان الاجهزه
المعنيه تتحقق من اثر هذه الاعتراضات على
الارض
من جهتها نقلت وكاله رويترز عن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت ثمان
دبابات لبارد يقاتل بها الاوكرانيون في
دونيتسك والحقت خسائر بشريه فادحه
وقالت الوزاره ان التشكيلات الروسيه احبطت
جميع محاولات القوات الاوكرانيه للتقدم في
دونتسك وتحدث المصدر عن نشر الاوكرانيين
قوات جديده في الجهه الشرقيه من مناطق
القتال